[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في الحلقه الماضيه تناولت معه
الملفات الساخنه في العراق داخليا وخارجيا
في بلد يتلمس طريقه الجديد بعد الاحتلال
الامريكي عام 2003 وبعد عقود من
الديكتاتوريه والحروب والمشاريع العباسيه
افضت الى سقوط البلاد في تيه الاحتلال
والاقتتال الداخلي لكننا لم نتعرف بشكل
مفصل على محمد الشياع السوداني اول رئيس
وزراء من عراقي الداخل وفي هذا الامر
دلاله بالغه الاهميه على القبول وتلمس
قضايا وحاجيات الشعب العراقي وكذلك في
الانتماء والعلاقات التي تقيد صاحبها ان
كانت بالغه الود وعميقه الوصل مع اي طرف
خارجي بدا السوداني نشاطه السياسي مع حزب
الدعوه الاسلاميه عضوا لمجلس محافظه ميسان
التي ينحدر منها لاسره متوسطه والده كان
موظفا في المصرف الزراعي وقد اعدم مع خمسه
من افراد عائلته عام 1980 بسبب الانت لحزب
الدعوه الاسلاميه الذي كان محظورا على ذاك
نال محمد الشياع البكالوريوس من جامعه
بغداد وتخرج مهندسا زراعيا في السنوات
الست التي سبقت الغزو الامريكيه للعراق
عمل في مديريه الزراعه بمحافظه ميسان
وتسلم مسؤوليات عده كان المهندس المشرف
على البرنامج الوطني العراقي للبحوث مع
منظمه الفاو التابعه للامم المتحده قبل
الغزو بعد عام 2003 عمل منسقا بين الهيئه
المشرفه على اداره محافظه ميسان وسلطه
الائتلاف للقوات الامريكيه وتولى بعد ذلك
قائم مقام في مدينه العماره مركز محافظه
ميسان عام 2004 وتقلد العديد من المناصب
الوزاريه حقوق الانسان الزراعه العمل
والشؤون الاجتماعيه الماليه والصناعه وفي
عام 2011 كلف بمهام رئيس الهيئه الوطنيه
للمسائله والعداله وبعد المظاهرات الشعبيه
او ما عرف بانتفاظ التشرين والتي انطلقت
بالعراق في اكتوبر عام 2019 قدم السودان
استقالته من حزب الدعوه الاسلاميه ليشكل
تيار الفراتين السياسي وتولى منصب الامين
العام للحزب الجديد وفي يوليو عام 2022
قرر الاطار التنسيقي ترشيحه لرئاسه
الوزراء في العراق مشاهدينا الكرام رئيس
الوزراء العراقي المهندس محمد الشيعه
السوداني ضيف المقابله في الجزء الثاني
فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
دوله رئيس الوزراء العراقي المهندس محمد
شيعه السوداني ضيف المقابله سعيد جدا
بوجودك معنا وبهذه الفرصه التي تتيحها لنا
للحديث معك وحول رئاسه الوزراء حول العراق
اهلا وسهلا بكم ونحن سعداء اكثر برنامجكم
من البرامج الشيقه الله يحفظك انا متابعه
الله يحفظك اليوم تمر
قرابه 20 سنه على ذكر احتلال العراق كيف
تنظر لهذا كيف ينظر رئيس الوزراء العراقي
بهذه العشرين سنه هذين العقدين ما جرى
فيهما
يعني لازم تستذكر انه وين كنا
وين وصلنا بعد العشرين سنه اكيد قبل
العشرين سنه قبل التغيير 2003
حروب عبثيه قتل تهجير صور مؤلمه عيشناها
المتحدث عايشها انا موجود في الثمانينات
في التسعينات
والحين التغيير
بعد التغيير الكل كان استبشر خير
نظام جديد دستور كتب بايادي منتخبة الكل
ثبت الحقوق والواجبات
لكن بدا فصل اخر لفصل الارهاب في الطائفي
القتل الممنهج يعني كانت
صور مؤلمه يوميا تواجهنا صور اشلاء
متناثره في الاسواق في الشوارع
فهذه تركه اثر الان انتهت في صوره او في
حلقه 11 اللي هي انهيار ثلث محافظات
العراق
خلال هذه الفتره اكيد كان هناك عمل انجز
شيء لكن المتوقع اكثر
صار تراجع لمستوى الاقتصاد التعليم
الخدمات كان يفترض نقدم افضل من اللي
قدمناه
نحترف اكو سوء اداره اكو استفحال لظاهره
خطيره اللي ظاهره الفساد
العراق دوله غنيه ولكن ايضا الفساد يوازي
هذا الغنى هو بصراحه يعني
هذا موظف من قبل 2003 الفساد كان الها
جذور حتى في زمن نظام السابق ان كان حصار
وكذا ووضع صعب لكن ما كانت بهذا الحجم
بحجم بحكم حجم الاموال ما بعد ثلاثه اموال
كبيره وما مو ذاك البطش البطش صدام حسين
قبل في زمن النظام قطع اليد اعدامات كذا
وفوضى صارت يعني هدرت اموال فاثرت على
مستوى التنميه والخدمات هذا بالمجمل تركه
اثر نفسي في على مستوى الشعب في مقبوليتهم
للعمليه السياسيه لذلك وصلتنا رسائل
قبلها
انتخابات 2018 كان عزوف
تشرين و21 ايضا بالانتخابات ايضا عزوف
كبير هاي رسائل الناس كانت تقول وما زالت
في العراق انه هذه الطبقه السياسيه التي
قادت العراق ما بعد 2003 لم تحقق الدرجه
الادنى من تطلعات الشعب العراقي هذا حكم
قاسي مبالغ فيه جدا بس لما تشوف الفساد
البطاله الفقر الصحيفه وتشوف ايضا الاحزاب
السياسيه دوله الرئيس وحضرتك يعني تعرف
هذا الامر اكثر انه في حاله تجينا ايضا
مقابل هذا
هو اللي تسبب الفساد هو قسم
تواجد بالسلطه واستخدم المنصب لاغراض
حزبيه شخصيه لكن انت من تتحدث عن بلد مرض
هذه التجربه بهذه الهزات العنيفه يعني
اكيد ظروفه مثاليه هذا مو تبرير
بنفس الوقت هناك
من وقف موقف وطني يحافظ على المال العام
اليوم ما تحقق شيء يعني بالارقام بالارقام
نقدر نثبت في كل محافظه في كل قريه في كل
تغير الوضع حسن شيء ولكن
دوله الرئيس من عراقيه داخل اول رئيس
وزراء بعد 2003 محمد شيعه السوداني من
عراقيين داخل هذا يفرق طبعا شو اللي يفرق
فيه يفرق انه هذا قريب من عندنا عاش ويانا
سنوات يفهمنا شنو اولوياتنا هذا مو معناها
الاخوه اللي اجوا من خارج كانوا يعني
بعيدين عن المواطن بس بحكم بطبيعه الحياه
والمعيشه والوضع
ترتيب الاولويات يجوز ما كانوا موفقين
فيها انا اعرف نفسيه وطبيعه المواطن
العراقي كنت موظف موظف
مهندس زراعيه في مديره زراعه نيسان
لحد 2003 انا موظفه ثم درجت في مواقع هذه
الحلقه مخصصه لجانب الشخصي المهندس
مواليد 1970 بالطابه والدك اعدم في عام
حزب الدعوه
طبيعه الاسره طبيعه نشاطها السياسي يعني
كان عمري عشر سنوات فاتذكر اتذكر
المجموعه اللي كانت معاه اللي هي كانت
مجموعه منتميه الى حزب الدوله الاسلاميه
نعم كان عندهم ايمان بمنهج الدعوه وكان
مهمتهم اسلاميه اكثر مما تكون سياسيه
سياسيه او معاديه للنظام تبليغ الاسلامي
مساعده العوائل اللي تعرضت للسجن في وقتها
كان هذا همهم المسكت الحلقه بدات
الاعترافات والدي كان في فرنسا كان
بالعلاج في الخارج
فوصل خبر للسفاره العراقيه في باريس
وارجعه بدون اجراء عمليه
كان عنده
قدمه بلاتين يعني جابوا الاسعاف واعدم وهو
عنده بلاتين نعم في سجن من اثر على
المهندس محمد وهو في العاشره يعدم والده
اكيد اثر نفسي كبير تعرف منزله وقيمه
الوالد والدي هم كان
مختلف تماما في كل شيء
وهذه ضاعفت المسؤوليتي انت الاكبر
بالعائله ولا الابن الاكبر بعد انت اصبحت
الاكبر لكن
اعضاء مسؤوليه في فتره صعبه حرب
الثمانينات ومن ثم دراسه وكذا مسؤوليه
عائله تدخل للحصار
لكن رغبه يعني كان عندك قطعا تركت رغبه
لديك في مواجهه هذا النظام الذي عدم والدك
في رفض النظام ممارساته كذا لكنه من
تسالني تقول لي ما بعد النظام تركت عندك
اثر للانتقام
فقه كان احد الاشخاص المتسببين في كتابه
التقرير الجيران معه وبالتالي من داخل من
داخل ولغايه يعني قبل ما اتواجد في بغداد
اسلم عليه واروح له بالعيد عايده وهو من
تسبب بالوشايه
يعني ما تركت اثر في نفسي انه انتقم
صرت يعني
اللي هي مختصه بالبحثين والاجهزه القمعيه
تعاملت معاها بجنب مهنيه صرف
الدعوه المهندس
بعد 2003 لكن قبل لا لا شباب
سياسي قبل 2003
لكن بعد 2003 تعرف
بدايه الاحزاب الاسلاميه بما فيها حزب
الدعوه الاسلام تتواجد
وتحتضن عوالي الشهداء بالسجناء كذا فكانوا
الاقرب
كلفت بمهام مقام العماره
لشخص
للحزب اسرتك ذات حضور
في المحافظه جدك كان شيخ هذه العشيه نعم
بعدين صار العمل ضمن حزب الدعوه في
انتخابات وكذا عضو مجلس محافظه دخلت
انتخابات ومن ثم محافظ
كموظف دوله قبل 2003 مهندس كرئيس وزراء
وافتقلته وزراء هل الوضع الاداري الهيكلي
البنيه كانت افضل قبل 2003 الوضع الاداري
في وقتها كان وضع متماسك
في اسس للوظيفه
في حزم في التعامل الوظيفي والمسؤوليه
الاداريه ماكو تعاون وهذا يرجع بسبب
النظام وبطشه
لكن السياقات موجوده
بس موجوده بحكم الحزب الواحد اللي هو
مسيطر على كل مفاصل الدوله يعني ماكو مجال
للخطا اللي يخطئ
تحاسب
كذا ما اجواء حريه
انفتاح بس ايضا الاحزاب اصبح لها وجود في
الدوله لان يقولون دوله الرئيس متخذ
قرارنا ما يتعين حد اليوم بعد تولي كاس
وزراء من خارج الوزارات من خارج الجهاز
الاداري لكل وزاره يعني
قبل القوى النافذه هذا موضوع تعني وهذا
واحد من اشكاليات العمليه السياسيه بعد
2003 مره نقول الاحزاب بتجتمع وتشكل حكومه
نسميها حكومه ائتلافيه هذا حق طبيعي
انه انت حزب تدخل الحكومه وتشترك وتقدم
وزير
ومره ثانيه لا تريد تجي انت تسيطر على
مفاصل الوزاره تجيب الوكيل والمدير العام
والمستشار وهذا خطا هذا خطا هذه تترك
للوزاره الجهاز الاساسي موظف المسلكي
المختص هو اللي مو شرط انتماءه لهذا الحزب
او ذاك
هذا اللي قاعد نواجهها لان هذا واحده من
سلبيات المرحله السابقه فهذا موقفي انا
متشدد فيها انه نعطي خصوصيه للموظف في هذه
الوزاره هو الاقدر على تبوء موقع
المسؤوليه هل تعافى العراق اليوم بعد 20
سنه من احتلالهم في عام 2003 في ظل هذه
الازمات السياسيه الامنيه
دخلنا كل تجارب اللي مرت يمكن على الدول
العالم كلها كلها طبقت في العراق اعتقد
استوعبنا الدرس الكل استوعب الدرس يعني
مثلا في بدايه العمل السياسي كان اكو قسم
طيف واسع بالمجتمع رافض للعمليه السياسيه
لا بدا يقتنع انه يدخل عمليه سياسيه واذا
عنده يغير
بدينا نفتهم حدود الحريات والديمقراطيه
بدينا نفتهم انه قدرنا كعراقيين بمختلف
مكوناتنا واطيافنا انه نعيش سويها في هذا
البلد هذا درس مهم ماكو مجال لالغاء الاخر
عهد السابق عهد صدام حسين كان هناك فئه
مستفيده بشكل كبير جدا وكان في فئات مهمشه
ومظلومه تمييز عنصري كانه في 2003 ما بعد
ثلاثه اصبح لدينا نفس المعادله بدرجه اخرى
لانه في فئات مستفيده وفي فئات ربما اكثر
تهميشا واقل استفاده في الفئه قبل 2003
اقليه تحكم
وكانت الطائفيه مو واضحه محصوره بنظام
الحكم باصحاب القرار وبمو مو فقط يعني من
مكون من جزء من قريه انا اقدر اسميها بكل
وضوح عصابه عصابه هي كانت تسيطر على
المقادير الامور ما كانت عندها الاسس
الصحيحه ايضا يجيبوه من الشارع ويخلوه
سفير ولا رتبه
اللي صار شنو مثلا لا تختلف
المجاهدين اللي كانوا في المعارضه المسلحه
اعتبروا وفترتهم الجهاديه هذه فتره خدمه
وهذه تجربه معموله في كل دول العالم
وبالتالي التقسيط عسكري
لكن واحد يصير وزير تقني في سياسي سفير
ايضا بدون خبره بدون معرفه الوزير منصب
سياسي
دخل الانتخابات فاز يريد يقدم نموذج يريد
يقدم نموذج ناجح في وزاره الصحه
حتى يقول الان القطاع الصحي تحسن في هذا
بسبب الرؤيه اللي يحملها هذا الحزب على
امر طبيعي لكن ما دون الوزير يترك للمهنيه
اللي صار بعد 2003
في مساله الهيمنه او كذا هو هذا اللي
اقوله اقول انه القوه السياسيه يفترض
تراعي مبدا المواطنه في مجالات تترك
للكفاءات للمستقلين بغض النظر ينتمي لهذا
الحزب او ذاك كون يعطى الفرصه
[موسيقى]
لا شك ان الغزو الامريكي للعراق عام 2003
نجح في تحقيق هدف كان بعيدا المنال تمثل
باسقاط النظام المستبد لكن بعد مرور عقدين
على تلك الحرب لا يبدو ان تغيب حكم الفرد
الواحد قد احدثت تغيير المنشود بحياه
العراقيين فرغم الاحتياطات النفطيه
الهائله لا تزال البنيه التحتيه من طرق
وجسور ومنشات في بلاد الرافدين متهالكه
ويعاني المواطنون من فقدان الخدمات
الاساسيه كانقطاع التيار الكهربائي وغياب
شبكات توزيع مياه الشرب ليس ذلك فحسب فقد
هيمنه النزاعات الطائفيه والمذهبيه
الداميه والسيارات المفخخه طويلا على
المشهد وتعرضت فئات كثيره من العراقيين
للانتقام او الاباده الجماعيه والارهاب
والتشريد
وجاءت سيطره تنظيم الدوله على ثلث مساحه
البلاد منتصف العام 2014 لتزيد الاوضاع
صعوبه وماساويه وهشاشه
وفي اكتوبر من العام 2019 شهدت بغداد ومدن
اخرى احتجاجات غير مسبوقه تمديدا باستفحال
الفساد وسوء الاداره اما في اكتوبر من عام
2021 فقد جرت انتخابات تشريعيه مبكره غير
ان الاتفاق على اسم رئيس جديد للوزراء
استغرق عاما كاملا بعد مواجهات عسكريه بين
ميليشيات المسلحه ورغم الكثير من العقبات
الا ان البعض يرى ان العراق قد احرز تقدما
منذ سقوط نظام صدام حسين في حين يجزم
البعض الاخر بان الفساد يشكل التحدي
الاكبر امام نهوض الدوله
يقارن من الجيد ان يكون رئيس الدوله ان لا
يكون قد ولد وفي فمه ملعقه من ذهب حتى
يكون على الاقل على نقول تماس كبير مع
حاجات الناس اريد ان اعود للعماره طفولتك
فيها العماره بطبيعه الريفيه
زراعيه فلاحين اهل نهر ما هي طبيعه الحياه
فيها
واساسا العشيره في منطقه ريفيه
بحكم المقاطعه والاراضي الزراعيه لكن
بيئتنا انا ولادتي بغداد
فما عشت كثير
مواليد انتقلنا اثنين وسبعين مع المرحوم
الوالد بحكم الوظيفه الى ميسان مركز
المحافظه العماره في المدينه كونه موظف
لكل حياتي لغايه 2003 تغيير وبعدها
استمريت
بالمواقع قائم مقام عضو مجلس محافظه محافظ
لمحافظه بيسان يعني المدينه التي ترارت
بها ثم انتقلت الى الوزاره مع الوزاره
بغداد رجعت لبغداد في حكومه السيد المالكي
عام 2010
ايضا كنت في بغداد اربع سنوات لاكمال
الدراسه في جامعه بغداد كليه زراعه
نعم فهذه الفتره ماذا تخصص في الزراعه في
تلك الفتره طبعا كان معدل المعدلات
العاليه في وقتها في سنتها لكنه بحكم
والدي معدوم كان اكو تمييز يعطونا رمز قيد
امنيه
يدفعنا من بعض الكليات يحولنا الى كليات
هذا يرجعني للتجربه الشخصيه دوله الرئيس
انت اعدم والدك عمرك عشر سنوات توليت
مسؤوليه الاسره على الاقل مع
كافي صعوبات كثيره اكيد الاسره ليست
ميسوره الحال ام اقل ام يعني اسره موظف
موظف طبعا عندما اعدم والدي ماكو راتب
تقاعدي
ايضا في عقاب
بمعنى فصل
يعني العائله تركت بدون اي مصدر معيشي فكن
انت
دبر نفسك في في تلك الظروف وظروف
الثمانينات وثم في الاصعب ظرف الحصار اللي
بعد واحد فكنا احنا اخوه اربعه اولاد
واثنين بنات فالاولاد كنا نشتغل شنو تشتغل
بالدراسه كل الاعمال كل الاعمال نعمل كل
واحد يعمل اكثر شي شغله البناء العماله
هنا نسميها
فكان احدنا يشتغل حتى يامن المصدر المعيشي
للعائله والباقيين يكملون دراسه وهكذا
عبرت للكليه
في بغداد
فكنت اعمل شفت مسائي
[موسيقى]
لمعانات شعبه مو فقط هذه انا بحكم وضعي
وجودي الاجتماعي العشيره
التواجد في
محافظاتنا نفهم طبيعه المواطن العراقي
اولوياته هواتف شنو مخاوفه شنو اللغه اللي
يفتهمها حتى نقدر نوصل بس الرؤساء الوزراء
اللي من خارج العراق اللي اشرنا لهم قبل
شوي حساسيتهم اقل يعني فيه في اشكاليه في
الفهم خاصه خرجوا من العراق
لهم العذر يعني تارك العراقي 30 25 سنه
فاكيد مو بذاك المستوى اللي يصل بسهوله
الى فهم مزاج المواطن بس قلت له شفت صدام
حسين
السوق حماده اللي
سماه صداميه الكرخ
فاحدى اللياليه قالوا رئيس راح يجيها
رئيس صدام حسين انا موجود حالنا حاله
الاموال المهندسين
فيدقق شوف التنفيذ والامانه
هذه المره الوحيده اللي يعني بس ما اقتربت
لا لا هذا يثيرني
يثيرني لتساؤل كبير جدا واظنه بدا يطرح في
العراق عن طبيعه النظام وطبيعه الدوله
وطبيعه الاداره ما قبل 2003 وما بعد 2003
كيف ترى الامرين وانت اليوم رئيس الوزراء
وعشت انت جزء من اداره الدوله من عشره 15
سنه يعني على مستوى
الحريات
يعني قبل
ثق مو نكته حقيقه
في اشخاص مواطنين عراقيين تم الحكم عليهم
بالسجن لانه حلم حلم انه صدام
سقط النظام او اتكلم عن النظام فهذا سولف
الحلم مالته وتروح الوشايه وتروح للاجهزه
الامنيه فتم الحكم عليها الان اللي يطلع
يتحدث على السوداني يتحدث على رئيس
الجمهوريه يتحدث عن نظام على كل رؤساء
الوزراء اي
اعتراض ممكن من موظف من مواطن ممكن يقيم
تظاهره
اعتصام اكو حريه تعبير اكو راي
الشيء الاخر والمهم انه هذه السلطه كلها
اساس الشعب بغض النظر عن ملاحظاتنا على
الانتخابات والمشاركه والعزوف لكن اليوم
الشرعيه الشرعيه من الشعب من الصندوق
الصندوق الانتخابي هو اللي ينتخب مجلس
النواب ومجلس النواب هو اللي يفرز الكتله
والحكومه ويصوت عليها
شرعيتنا من اصوات المواطنين وهذه الميزه
شقد صارت
مشاكل سياسيه امنيه من 2003 الشيء
الايجابي في العراق انه حافظنا على
الانتقال السلمي للسلطه تداول
ما صار دوره بعد دوره حتى الفائز وما
يتمكن من تشكيل كتله اكبر يسلم بالامر
الواقع ويقتنع ويقول الطرف الاخر شكل
الكتله اكبر فهو الاولى بتشكيل حكومه يسلم
بالامر الاخر حادثه الشيء ايجابي وهذا مع
مرور الوقت صار نضج وفهم للعمليه السياسيه
كم محتاجنا حتى نوصل للمرحله هذي دوله
الرئيس بعد 2003 خاصه انه الديمقراطيه
العراق هي ديمقراطيه يعني طائفيه اثنيه
عرقيه وايضا مغروسه غرس من الخارج يعني
بالفعل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومجلس
الحكم في ذاك الوقت حتى تعريف الناس كان
تعريفا انه هذا شيعي هذا كردي هذا سني لم
يكن العراق معتادا على هذا الامر
هو التمايز كان موجود قبل 2003 لكن مسيطر
عليه بقوه النظام يعني احنا في محافظه
بيسان ما عندنا رئيس وحده اداريه من اهالي
المحافظه
ياتينا من محافظه محدده اللي هي من
محافظات يعني
بس قصدي التمييز بين مكون واخر كان فيه في
القوميه الكرديه ما مسموح لها يعني الا في
بعض المواقع اللي يتم اختيارها ماكو شي
اسمه مشاركه او حقوق المكونات
وحريه الاديان والشعر هذا ما كان موجود
بعد 2003 هذه المكونات نتيجه هذا الكبت
ومصادره الحقوق وهذه وحده من الاشكاليات
اللي اشرت على الدستور الكل بدا يطرح
مخاوفه ويثبت حقوقه في الدستور فهنا برزت
الهويات الفرعيه بشكل اوضح قياسا للهويه
الوطنيه اللي هي التي تسود مع اعتزازنا
بكل العناوين الفرعيه لكن الوطن والعراق
المظله هو العراق
[موسيقى]
السؤال اللي يعني هذا كان مفهوم اول الامر
انا اقصد انه ايضا رده الفعل استمرت ثمت
كانه مكون ماء وهو المكون العراقي الشيعي
هو الذي يسيطر على مقاليد الامر
صارت شلون يعني اليوم مثلا في كل
الانتخابات في كل الدورات السابقه
المكون الشيعي هو ياخذ نصف زاد واحد
النصف زائد واحد يقدر ينتخب رئيس برلمان
ويقدر يتفق
وينتخب رئيس جمهوريه ويقدر يشكل حكومه
لوحده طيب ليش هذا المكون ما صار به هذا
الخيار شكل مفردا
لايمانه بانه لا يمكن ان تدار الامور بدون
مشاركه باقي المكونات حتى كلهم يكونون جزء
من اداره الدوله وهذا عامل الاطمئنان
وهكذا صارت الامور تشوف الحكومه فيها
الطيف العراقي
الرئاسات الثلاث فضلا انه انا ما عندنا
اليوم انا رئيس وزراء
ما عندي صلاحيه مطلقه اليوم انا صلاح اكو
فصل بين السلطات عندي صلاحيات واحد اثنين
ثلاثه اكو سلطه برلمانيه اكو سلطه قضائيه
اكو فصل بين السلطات ماكو صلاحيه مطلقه
لرئيس بقاء هذه العناوين دوله الرئيس ان
رئاسه الوزراء حكرا على المواطنين
العراقيين الشيعه والرئاسه الجمهوريه على
المواطنين العراقيين الاكراد ورئاسه
البرلمان هذا النظام الطائفي الموجود في
لبنان على سبيل المثال يعني بقاء هذه
العناوين هو بذاته اصلا ينشئ حاله طائفيه
هو
دستوريه ماكو شي مكتوب هذا التصنيف وانما
بحكم العرف الذي ساد ومن باب مشاركه كل
المكونات في القرار
تواجدت هذه
التسويق او التوزيعه
بالبواقع والمشاركه والا ماكو شي يمنع
بكره
كتله من البرلماني يضم عده مكونات ممكن
تختار سني او كردي دراسه الحكومه والعكس
دستوريه لا شيء دستوريه نمنع ولا ايضا
يعني يجوز
شعبيا ممكن يمنح الناس الان بدا يشوف هذا
النضج اللي اقول لك عليه هذا النضج في
العمليه السياسيه في فهم النظام السياسي
ما بعد 2003 بدا يكبر شيئا فشيئا ماكو
محددات
اكو شيعه انتخبه وسنه والعكس اكو شيعه
مسيحي كنائب اكو شيعه
نائب احد الدواب قال انا جمهوري من الشيعه
خود تختلف الديانه لكنه يشوفوه مواطن قريب
لهم يؤدي دوره هذا شيء ايجابي
العمليه الديمقراطيه في العراق في كل
تجارب العالميه ترى استغرقت خمسين سنه
وكذا احنا عشرين سنه في ظروف غير مستقره
يعني احنا ما اترك العراق لوحده يمارس
حياته الطبيعيه لا قاعده وارهاب وعصابات
جريئه
والتخيير ما كان تغيير طبيعي وجود احتلال
وامريكان وكذا وتدخلات وهواجس اقليميه
وكذا ونفوذ هنا وهناك هذا الوضع مو وضع
مثالي حتى تكون عمليه بناء الديمقراطيه
تراكميه بشكل طبيعي قطعا يصير بيها او خلل
لكن بالنتيجه اقول ان العمليه نضجت بشكل
واضح جدا قبل تشكيل حكومتي كان هناك
تجاذبات سياسيه خطيره
لكن وين كان التنافس كان التنافس بالدستور
بالمحكمه الاتحاديه هذا اللي يريد يشكل
ثلث ضامن ذاك يشكل ثلثين ذاك اللي يريد
يشتكي بالمحكمه الاتحاديه رغم انه السلاح
متوفر والرجال الموجودين
الشيء اللي كان حاضر انه الكل مؤمن انه
تداول سلمي للسلطه هذه الايجابيه دوله
الرئيس انت ابن اسره تعرضت لعذابات اعدم
والدك في في فتره مبكره وابن مكون ايضا
تعرض لاضطهاد في فتره النظام السابق واضحه
كانت تفاصيل هذا الامر اليوم انت في موقع
المسؤولي هل تشعر ايضا
بالاضطهاد او بالحق الناقص لبعض المواطنين
العراقيين من مكونات ثانيه على سبيل
المثال العراقيين السنه اليوم في حديث
واضح عن المظالم ويدفعون اثمانا لنظام
سابق لم يكن نظاما يعني كان نظاما عشائريا
كان نظاما عصبويا لم يكن نظاما سنيا
بالمعنى طبعا لا يمكن لاحد
ان تعرض للظلم
ويذهب الى ممارسه
الظلم بيده تجاه الاخر بالعكس هذا كان غير
دافع لي ولغيره ممن تعرضوا الى الظروف
المرحله السابقه انه
يبدون بدايه جديده
بعيدا عن الاستهداف
والانتقام وانا ذكرت لحضرتك انا رغم انه
فقدت خمسه من افراد عائلتي لكن عندما كلفت
في اداره هيئه معنيه بالوسائل اللي فيها
خصوصا الانتقام كبار البحثين والاجهزه
القمعيه لم اتصرف وفق منطق الثار
والانتقام ابدا وانما كانت اهم فتره
بالنسبه للمشمولين كون القانون طبق
بحذافيره والكل يعلم هذه
اليوم ماكو استهداف
اداره السجود السياسي
كثير من الوزارات اليوم ماكو استهداف
للمكون السني على انه جزء من النظام
السابق لانه حتى المكون السن يتعرف للظلم
في زمن النظام السابق
محمد مظلوم ابو نمر
الجبور
مجازر صارت ضد الكثير من المكونات
والشخصيات السنيه في زمن النظام السابق
يعني هو مو فقط الظلم توزع اختص به جهه
نعم قد يكون اوضح مكون قوميه لكن
وزع النظام صدام على الجميع ما بعد 2003
نعم كان جزء مهم من المكون رافض لي عمليه
التغيير ما مؤمن بالعمليه السياسيه يعني
اللي صوت على الاشتراك في كتابه الدستور
في وقتها كان فقط الحزب الاسلامي
في وقت طيف اخر مجموعه من بعض السياسيين
عندهم تحفظ مع مرور الوقت اصبح الكل مؤمن
انه هذه العمليه السياسيه باقيه اذا كانوا
من الملاحظات ندخل من خلال العمليه
السياسيه اثنين الارهاب من دخل الارهاب ما
يمثل السنه نعم هو تواجد في مناطق سنيه
لكنه اول ما بطش بالسنه باهل السنه اول
جريمه لداعش عندما دخلت الموصل هو اعدام
14 امام جامع
في مدينه الموصل الموصل فهي لم تكن ثوره
للسنه ضد النظام السياسي وانما اصابه
ارهابيه
جاءت وتسللت في هذه المناطق اكثر الضحايا
في تلك المحافظات يعني المكون تهجير
والسبيل
السبيل بالنسبه للمكونات وفق عقليه وايد
لوجيه داعش لكن النزوح اللي اتجاوز ثلاثه
مليون منهم للمحافظات تعرضوا لتجربه مريره
عالم منعتها من تلك الجرائم من مصلحه
النظام السياسي
ان لا يذهب وفق عناوين ثريه
وفق خلفيات قوميه او دينيه مو بمصلحه
العراق هذا التنوع اللي موجود
قطعا هو عامل قوه وليس عامل ضعف هل يشكل
نظام صدام حسين والطريقه التي اجرت فيها
وشخصيه عقده لدى النظام السياسي اللي هو
الجديد بعد 2003 يعني دائما ما يتم ترداد
هذا الامر
ليس عقده وانما درس لكل من يتواجد في
الحكم
ان ينظر معه مصير من يطغى يظلم يقتل
ويسرق
يذهب بالبلاد بسياسات عبثيه هذا درس لنا
سواء كنا المتصدين او
للعراقيين عموما
هذا ما انا شخصيا ما اضعه امامي اضع مصلحه
العراق فوق اي اعتبار لان القرار اللي
اتخذه هو قرار يخص كل العراقيين بكل
اطيافهم مقرار وفق نزعه شخصيه رؤيه خاصه
بشخص محمد السوداني يجتهد ويتخذ القرار لا
وين العراق من هذا القرار وان مصلحه
العراقيين جميعا من هذا القرار مؤخرا
بدانا نشعر بشكل كبير بالعراق دوله الرئيس
بمعنى اراده العراق كانت مسلوبه جزئيا في
السنوات الاولى ما بعد 2003 الى فتره
قريبه اما امريكيا اما ايرانيا كانت دائما
يعني كان دائما الحدث يعبر عن او يمثل
مصالح اخرى اكثر بالفتره الاخيره بدانا
نشعر بان ثمه عراق ثمه مصلحه عراقيه وطنيه
ثم احاديث عنه
متى يكتمل هذا المشهد مشهد العراقي الوطني
الذي يتعامل مع الاخرين بشكل جيد يبني
علاقات جيده ليس بالضروره يعني يحارب
الاخرين سواء ايران ولا غير لكنه لا يكون
مسلوب الاراده لهذه الاطراف السياسيه سواء
الامريكيه او ايرانيه يعني
قد اختلف مع حضرتك في هذا الوصف مسلوب
الاراده في 2003 تعرضنا الاحتلال وبقرار
مجلس امن وانتهينا من الاحتلال رسميا في
لانه كان فعلا احتلال بعد 2011 الدوله
بمؤسساتها بدات هي اللي تحكم وهي اللي
تتخذ القرار وهي التي تمارس السياساتها
القمه العربيه عقدت في بغداد
في هذا القصر القمه العربيه في سنه 2012
كانت اراده عراقيه وطنيه لم تكن اراده
ايرانيه او امريكيه وانما وجد العراق انه
من مصلحه العرب ان يتواجدوا في في بغداد
وكان واحده من الاخطاء
الستراتيجيه للعرب انهم ابتعدوا عن العراق
يعني احنا عندنا خطاين استراتيجيين المكون
السني عدم مشاركته في العمليه السياسيه
بقوه عدم اتخاذ ايضا العرب يعني راوا انهم
غير معنيين بالعراق بعد 2003 تركوه طويلا
واحترفوا بعد خصوصا بعد داعش وتهديد داعش
مكان تهديد فقط للعراق ابدا كان تهديد
كبيره كانت تستهدف المنطقه اللي وقف امام
هذه المؤامره امام هذه العصابات العراقيون
بصراحه نيابه عن المنطقه العالم
هنا ايقن الجميع انه ضروره عوده العرب
للعراق وليس عوده العراق العراق كان موجود
وحاضر
والامس كانت ثمه ابدا ثق طبيعه المواطن
العراقي
العشائريه والاجتماعيه والجذور عربيه
اصيله
ممتده بالجزيره العربيه وعنده عشق لاشقاء
بشكل لا يوصف خليجي 25 واضح شو اللي صار
بالبصره كل الناس تتكلم عن البصره وعلى
العراق هذا هذا الترحاب وعن يعني انا حتى
شعرت انها مبالغه لكن انا ترى دخلت من
منفذ صفوان البري
من صفوان من الكويت الى صفوان الى بغداد
وهذا يعني شفته بعيده الحقيقه لكن اللي
حصل في خليجي دوره الخليج في البصره شيء
استثنائي يعني كان الكل متلهف لبعض سواء
خليجيين متلهفين والعراقيين متلهفين
لاخواتهم العرب شو اللي صار فقه هو تعبير
عفوي عن حقيقه الشخصيه العراقيه يعني احنا
في الزيارات الزيارات الدينيه لكربلاء
تعرف الزيارات مليونيه خمسه مليون سته
مليون ياتون من كل
تلاحظ المواكب على طول الطرق خدمه ماكل
ومشرب هذه طبيعه العراق في خليجي 25
اشقاء يدخلون لاول مره
ترى الشباب الخليجي ما شايف العراق كلهم
كانوا في لهفه اصدقاء قالوا بس بنروح يشوف
البصره ونرجع يعني يوم ما هو من اهله من
هذا كبار البصره وتعرف البصره طبيعه
وحتى بغداد يعني كثير من الاصدقاء
الخليجين هم دراستهم بغداد جامعه بغداد
الشباب الخليجيه ما كان شايف العراق يسمع
فوجد هذا في هذه البطوله فرصه ان يتقرب من
هذا البلد الجار
كان واضح امامه الشعب العراقي بيعه فويت
في المطعم في الشارع في التفسير في الفندق
ومثل ما ذكرت لحضرتك انا لحد الان منطي
سماح في التاشيره الدخول ويوميا العشرات
يدخلون
يتعللون بالبصره وبالليل يرجعون للكويت او
اللي يريد يسافر للاقليم للمدن المقدسه
من طرف واحد من طرف واحد ليش ما يقابلونها
بعد الخليجين يسمح اكبر انا قلت لهم حتى
ولو من طرف واحد بس ايضا العراق بحاجه
لهذا احنا
نقول ما في تاشيره الخليجين
لا مجرد يدخل خاتمه ويدخل في المنفذ صفوان
وهذا راح التجربه شنو استفدتوا استفدنا
منها
كانت فرصه انه ننظم لاول مره بطوله من
اربعين عام تعبر عن تعافي الدوله
متعافيه بكل
السياقات الامنيه الاداريه الخدميه وفرنا
قدمنا نموذج استوعبنا هذا الجمهور اثنين
وفرنا فرصه انه يطلع الاشقاء الاصدقاء
الضيوف الاجانب انه اكو دوله مستقره فيها
امين فيها سلطه وفيها مؤسسات ومنشات وفيها
جمهور متحضر يعني الجمهور العراقي في
الدقيقه سته وتسعين
المنتخب العماني يجي بالتعادل وهو ساكت
ويشجع
مع بعض الملاحظات على الدوره طبيعي
ملاحظه مؤشر صحيح انت اكو جماعه يمس بحاجه
لمعرفه ماذا ماذا يجري في العراق هو هذا
اللي استفدنا
نبقي هذا
الاجراءات تسهيل دخول سمه الدخول حتى الكل
يطلع على الواقع
نشوفه في الوفود التي تاتي لبغداد وفود
رسميه مؤتمرات كذا ايضا نفس الكلام اللي
تفضلت فيه يقول انا متردد كذا
زوجتي توصلني للمطار قلت له وين جايب لي
حرب يعني رايحين هذه الوضع الطبيعي يروح
جوا في بغداد في محافظات لكن هذا يحتاج
الى برنامج دوله الرئيس برنامج للعراق
رسمي تقوده الدوله لاستقطاب الناس طبعا
بالدرجه الاساس الدوله تتحمل يفترض عندها
رسائل مو رساله رسائل اطمئنان عبر كل
القنوات حتى تكسر هذا الحاجز من الخلق
وبنفس الوقت المؤسسات الاعلاميه المهنيه
العربيه والعالميه دائما العراق مظلوم من
هذه الناحيه كثير ما يتم التركيز على
الصوره السلبيه دائما وتترك كثير من
الايجابيات من المشاريع من المنجزات من
الابداع من الصور الوطنيه اللي يقدمها
الشعب العراقي بكل اطيافه ما يصير تركيز
عليها
فهذه بالتاكيد مسؤوليه مهنيه اخلاقيه
تجتمع عليها كل المؤسسات وفي مقدمتهم
الجزيره بالتاكيد ابن ميسان الذي توفي او
اعدم والده شابا صغيرا طفلا صغيرا في
العاشره والذي عانى واخوته في العمل
وتوفير لقمه العيش ومسانده يعني والدتهم
والدراسه والعمل اثناء الدراسه
والعراقي يعيش هذا التحول الكبير ثم يصبح
ابن ميسان وابن العماره رئيس الوزراء
العراقي ويقود اليوم صاحب القرار الاول في
العراق كيف تنظر لهذا المشهد دوله الرئيس
كلهم يعني شرف كبير لي ان اكون في خدمه
الشعب في خدمه العراق
فرصه اشكر الله سبحانه وتعالى
انهيئها لي حتى اكون خادم لهذا الشعب بهذا
السجل بهذا التاريخ من المعاناه من الصبر
من الالم
ان اتحسس الام ومعاناه الابناء شعبنا وما
اكثرها من معاناه في ظل الظروف الحاليه
انا يوميا عمل ما ابالغ اذا اقول 17 ساعه
انا سمعت هذا الكلام من
يعمل فعلا
فريقي متاذي من
المواكبه العمل ليش لان اقول هذه فرصه
وابناء الشعب العراقي يستحقون الخدمه
عراقي انطى كل شيء لبلده
اعز ما يملك ابنائهم
الدماء الطاهره من اجل العراق يعني انت
تصور ام لحد الان اتذكر هذا المشهد
ام عراقيه انطت خمس اولاد من اهل
الديوانيه
ويسالها مقدم قناه الحره
يقول لها شنو
موقفك رئيس حجيه تقول له فدوه للعراق
خمس اولاد شهداء في الحرب على داعش تقول
له فدوه للعراق
هؤلاء شهداء قاتلوا في مناطق جغرافيا
بعيده عن الديوانيه قد تكون قوميات واديان
وسيع يزيد
ولم يراعوا قضيه وانما قاتلوا من اجل
العراق شوف هذا الشعب الشعب عظيم
الكل تجاوز الطائفي
والتفرقه
والكل يتسابق من كل الاطياف في خدمه لكنه
لم يكافا كما يجب هنا مسؤوليه من تجي
وتقول لي انت بهذا الرؤيه بهذا الاطلاع
كيف
تعمل ما هو المطلوب منك بالتاكيد مطلوب
مني العمل ليل نهار حتى نعيد ثقه الشعب
بالدوله ومؤسساتها ونكون خدمه حقيقيا
لرئيس الوزراء العراقي السيد محمد شيعه
السوداني ضيف المقابله في الحلقه الثانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذا الوقت الذي
منحتنا شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه دمتم
بخير القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل
في حلقه جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]